I have the new Virgin Mary Queen with me
tonight car TV so I wanted to do
something divine of divinity for her so
I thought about the Vatican and all
these amazing encrusted iconography of
religious icons like Mary tonight well
clearly I'm not but you know I thought I
saw Jeremy I want something very
Catholic I want something that you've
seen a Catholic Church I'm Catholic and
I really wanted my religion to be
embraced in my outfit you had any baby
kicks with this dress huh nobody baby
kicks oh hey she wants to fight me it's
hard enough to get up the Met Gala
stairs now you got a baby kick yes are
you feeling in your pregnancy I feel
very happy I feel like I want to work I
fool I don't know I feel very energetic
to keep on going like powerful like like
a woman like a woman so how many
fittings how many dresses how many tries
we knew what we wanted tell me something
about this dress that we wouldn't know
the fabric it weighs a ton of pit ball
he weighs about 45 pounds 50 pounds it's
okay though you know I used to go up the
project what does it feel like to be
from New York City and now to be here at
the biggest fanciest red carpet of the
year it feels like a dream and I'm very
grateful because I'm with a designer
that I love they're always telling my
performance look and it's like I feel so
comfortable it's just like I'm going out
with my best friend
I think that we should also note that
cardi is the star the universe has been
waiting for and that's why everyone
loves her
[Music]
[Applause]